now UK's new Chancellor Jeremy Hunt has
just made a statement let's have a
listen
17 and 20.
21 the new vat free shopping scheme for
non-uk visitors or the freeze on alcohol
Duty rates
secondly the government's current plan
is to cut the basic rate of income tax
to 19
from April 2023.
it is a deeply held conservative value
a value that I share
that people should keep more of the
money they earn
but at a time when markets are rightly
demanding commitments to sustainable
public finances it is not right to
borrow to fund this tax cut
so I've decided that the basic rate of
income tax will remain at 20 percent
and it will do so indefinitely until
economic circumstances allow for it to
be cut
taken together with a decision not to
cut corporation tax
and restoring the top rate of income tax
the measures I've announced today will
raise every year around 32 billion
pounds
finally the biggest single expense in
the growth plan was the energy price
guarantee
this is a landmark policy supporting
millions of people through a difficult
winter
and today I want to confirm that the
support we are providing between now and
April next year will not change
but beyond that the Prime Minister and I
have agreed it would not be responsible
to continue exposing public finances to
unlimited volatility in international
gas prices
so I'm announcing today a treasury-led
review into how we support energy bills
Beyond April next year
the objective is to design a new
approach that will cost the taxpayer
significantly less than planned
whilst ensuring enough support for those
in need
any support for businesses will be
targeted to those most affected
and the new approach will better
incentivize Energy Efficiency
the most important objective for our
country right now is stability
governments cannot eliminate volatility
in markets but they can play their part
and we will do so because instability
affects the prices of things in shops
the cost of mortgages and the values of
Pensions
there will be more difficult decisions
I'm afraid on both tax and spending as
we deliver our commitment to get debt
falling as a share of the economy over
the medium term
all departments will need to redouble
their efforts to find savings
some areas of spending will need to be
cut
but as I promised at the weekend our
priority in making the difficult
decisions that lie ahead will always be
the most vulnerable
and I remain extremely confident about
the UK's long-term economic prospects
as we deliver our mission to go for
growth
but growth requires confidence and
stability and the United Kingdom will
always pay its way
this government will therefore take
whatever tough decisions are necessary
to do so
thank you
there's Jeremy Hunt UK's Finance
administer making statements on tax and
spending measures he was expected to
u-turn on more of the government's tax
cutting plans and indeed the government
will reverse almost all of the tax
measures announcing Liz truss's economic
plan uh let's cross the general Hull is
outside the bank of England in London
and Jane is pretty much is expected to
pulling back of this the mini budget put
in place by the previous Chancellor
but more or less as as teased ahead of
this pre-recorded statement by the new
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt there uh clearly
trying to get ahead of the statement he
will make to Parliament later he wants
this fed into the markets as soon as
possible uh by my count I mean what he's
announcing there essentially is the
further decimation of that mini budget
statement put out by the former
Chancellor classic part 10 designed of
course in conjunction with Liz trust
that had caused so much trouble on the
markets as I say by my account only
about two-thirds or only about a third
of that budget will remain now intact
namely a stamp Duty cut and the cut in
National Insurance tax that's a tax paid
by all uh workers in this country
towards their state pension and so on
those uh remain but everything else uh
goes the 1p cut in the basic tax rate
that goes the cup the planned rise in
corporation tax will now go ahead we do
that on Friday of course vat free
shopping goes the big announcement
really and it impacts politically on his
trust is what Jeremy Hunt was saying
about the energy price guarantee that
was announced ahead of that tax cutting
package uh in response to the massive uh
increase in the rate particularly the
cost of gas off the back of the war in
Ukraine the government had announced an
enormous package tens of billions of
pounds worth called the energy price
guarantee that would have fixed the
price of units of gas electricity for
households for two years he says that is
now under review post April next year
when they will be looking at a much more
targeted set of measures looking at the
worst off in particular the reason this
is so toxic for this trust is because
really that had been the measure that
she'd Fallen back on amid all the
criticism of the government's budget
that had spooked the markets she
constantly fell back on this idea that
they had worked primarily to keep Energy
prices low for people for two years with
the chancellor here at junking that
measure on top of everything else it
will only add to Liz truss's problems
but no doubt good and comforting words
of reassurance this for the markets who
will welcome this return to a much more
Orthodox way of doing business of doing
fiscal policy essentially raising taxes
raising public spending cuts that the
government had promised would not happen
this will be good news for the markets
all right well that's the scene at the
bank of England General reporting there
Let's cross over to Westminster Andrew
Simmons joins us from there and Andrew
we knew this was coming but when you
hear it in the cold light of day how Liz
truss's economic plan has been almost
entirely reversed the question is clear
isn't it how can she survive this
this has been an extraordinary spell in
political drama in fact what a
difference four days make everything's
gone reverse and it's it's good for the
markets but it's bad for Liz trust she
is desperately holding on everything
that that that's positive about the
situation right now hasn't really got a
lot to do with her decision making it
it's been down to hunt to actually get
stuck in at the treasury up the road
there and really work hard then on
Sunday night going to out to Checkers
the country Retreat for the Prime
Minister uh don't read too much into
that she can't really do much with the
situation because there she is with the
the chancellor being more or less told
rip up everything you've put to the
public and you put to the conservative
party in order to gain power so she's in
a situation now where she's more or less
using uh the list of things and not all
of them uh that Rishi sunak the former
Chancellor and the last government
in taking on
um him she had all these tax cutting
plans which which really sold her uh to
the conservative party now those people
who are in government supporting us she
chose her supporters not her enemies
with her government which was a
dangerous thing to do because well not a
not exactly dangerous but not very
clever because she ended up in a
situation where they're all now saying
well you've basically
um let us down you've you've you've let
letters alone you've you've really sold
us to the river now on the other side
She's accused of ruining the
conservative party wrecking the
conservative party's reputation as being
the steward of the economy throughout
history absolutely wrecked and you've
got a conservative party now it's being
questioned as to whether it can govern
itself let alone govern the country and
so she's in a position now where yes the
markets are calmed it would seem and
they may well become further after that
uh raft of measures which the chancellor
has announced but she's now got to face
the music uh whether whether it will be
long Hall whether it be short haul
there's so much scheming going on right
now here in Parliament that you you
could not even start to estimate how
many lines of thinking there are but
there is this and that is the 1922
committee incredibly effective
backstabbing and Incredibly effective at
getting rid of prime ministers it could
be at work sooner rather than later it
depends who you listen to but there are
two ways of looking at it this could be
that in the short term everything will
be fine she'll be given a chance to try
and hold things together and for that
you will need obviously she'll need uh
hunt the chancellor to continue with
these measures and then she'll also need
the one nation side of the party that's
the center ground whereas she's holding
the right ground she'll need that side
of the party to survive and she'll be
meeting the caucus of that side of the
party uh in a short while it would seem
around about lunchtime apparently she
will hope to get support from them
whether that will be the case is
anybody's question indeed and so it goes
on and we'll do no doubt for some time
yet Andrew thanks for that Andrew
Simmons there in Westminster